president biden insisting recession is
not inevitable in his first press
interview since february the 10th the
commander-in-chief also admitting quote
people are really really down the need
for mental health in america it has
skyrocketed because people have seen
everything upset but most of it's the
consequence of what happened what
happened as a consequence of the covet
crisis he's blaming kovid for america
being in a bad mood fox business host
charles payne joins us right now with
reaction so it was wide-ranging this
interview
people are in a are hacked off because
of covet he says and he says that a
recession is not inevitable do you buy
that no i don't buy it i got to tell you
something
what we're witnessing right now is is
the failure of people that we that were
that been put in charge
by epic proportions and both have the
same problem jerome powell and president
biden
not listening to the average american
not listening know what they've all know
what they've done for the last two years
they told us how we feel
instead of listening to us telling them
how we felt
so now all of a sudden they're all
surprised pal's shocked at what's
happening all he had to do was visit a
supermarket a couple of times that's all
he had to do
president biden the same thing i got to
tell you this is very frustrating
because
the arrogance of saying uh you know
first to your point that he he's blamed
everything right and now trying to
equate this to the mental health crisis
that came from you know the lockdowns
instead of being honest just be honest
once this it's not too late
your policies have wrecked the average
lives of americans and the what's really
the sad part because we all make
mistakes
you did it deliberately
you deliberately wanted gasoline prices
to go higher you deliberately did this
you deliberately have
taken this this great nation
and you've got it wobbly
because you want to change fundamentally
change bro to borrow president obama as
those saying they fundamentally want to
change who we are as a nation the war on
capitalism the war for profit
corporations right now it's oil
companies but anyone who's in business
whether you own a stock a store on main
street
anyone who's in business to try to make
money maybe buy a house maybe send their
kids to college be warned this is a war
against you as well
one of the things that uh he was
responding to was the ins the
insinuation by the ap reporter that look
there are a lot of republicans and
people from the obama
administration actually who have said
that a lot of the inflation that we got
was because of the government spending
the gigantic government spending but do
you you remember this remember one of
the criticisms by the obama people at
the time back when they were pumping
billions of dollars into the economy was
you know what we didn't go big enough
well now joe biden is president and they
went
full tilt yeah but by the time president
biden got into office we had already
authorized 13.9 trillion dollars
trillion trillion dollars we'd already
authorized it and given out 10 trillion
of it so we already had 10 trillion we
came into 2021 with the strongest
household balance sheets in history the
strongest corporate balance sheets in
history we had momentum we had a vaccine
there was no need for the extra money
the stemi sparked a wage spiral paying
people not to work created you know this
year steve not a single month has small
business that has had net job gains
businesses with one in 19 employees
every single month this lear have lost
employees they can't compete in this
world that president biden has created
you want to talk about mental health yes
the owners of those people who've worked
20 30 years saved up all their money
says i'm going to open up that sandwich
shop i'm going to use grandma's recipes
and we're going to make it yes we are
now yeah they are suffering and he
should he should contemplate that and he
should really take it to heart because
he's in a position of power to change it
although i fear he won't
why would he he's got the midterms he's
knows that uh it's going to be a
bloodbath for democrats you change it
because you care about the country you
really do at some point you say listen
just like you know
these folks who go to college and the
professor tells them about all these
wonderful things of socialism and you
know it sounds so wonderful it's fair
it's nice but in real life the
application of it which by the way we
saw last year we see the consequences
now all right speaking of consequences
it sounds like elon musk had an all
hands on deck meeting yesterday he held
up his smartphone world's richest guy
didn't even hire a cameraman he's just
taken pictures of himself
they saw that here's one of the things
he said musk said he's in favor of
moderate politics and he's pretty close
to center and he would allow a diverse
range of views on the platform including
extreme views that are within the
parameters of the law he also said he'd
like to get to a billion users and when
asked if he was going to slash jobs he
said right now costs exceed revenue and
that's not a great situation that's
business 101
although he did say if you're a top
producer you can work from home if
you're a slacker bring your you know
what in because uh we need you to maybe
shore you up a little bit make sure you
belong at the company
you know what uh charles belongs at the
company and he's going to be here
through the afternoon watch him over in
fox business at two o'clock this
afternoon with making money but
unfortunately on wall street we're just
losing money right now right now it's
going to turn around all right charles
thank you very much a lot i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis